robert has spent thousands of pounds
making sure his business is covered
secure
but come the autumn he might have to
check if every customer has been
vaccinated before he can let them in
it's extra cost and it's
extra burden on the restaurant
especially on a small restaurant like
ours which is not on a high street and
relies on uh
just on the local customers who are
coming in
day in and day out so it's going to be
just extra expense and it's
i think it's going to be a nightmare to
be honest with you government
sources say covert 19 certificates might
be required before customers can enter
bars restaurants
and nightclubs a not so subtle warning
to those mainly young people who've not
yet been vaccinated if it was something
that was mandatory
it may cause me to change my lifestyle
slightly so for example maybe not eating
at certain places
it's okay for travel just to make sure
that you have vaccines but to go in
in the restaurants pubs i think it's
pointless there has to be some kind of
way that
we all feel confident again to sit down
and
no longer be locked away like hamsters
in a cage but the organization
representing the hospitality industry
says this will cost businesses even more
at a time when they're trying to recover
from the pandemic
you need two members of staff to man the
door to check people's covered status
and that simply means that businesses
are unviable even if they're trading at
full capacity
so you are putting hospitality again
into a situation
where it's trading at a loss it cannot
break even and it will push many
businesses towards the edge of viability
the problem is cases of covet are rising
one in 160 people in england have the
virus right now
that's a 60 increase in a week rising
cases means more people will have to
self-isolate
and for the nhs in particular that could
lead to staff shortages
the need for staff to be self-isolating
is adding to the pressures
but that staff self-isolating means that
there are work pressures and staffing
pressures
but there are still more people coming
through the doors than ever before
despite all the talk about freedom day
on july the 19th when the majority of
the remaining restrictions will be
lifted
those in government and the scientists
advising them
know that this is far from over mcmartin
sky news